POLITICAL THEATER, THAT'S WHAT
IT IS.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
AND BREAKING TODAY AND WHAT IS
JUST THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF THE
LESS REAL PSYCHOTIC.
I MEAN, THIS IS NOW A
DERANGEMENT.
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE.
THE NEW YORKER NOW FEATURES THIS
COVER.
IT SHOWS THE PRESIDENT AND RUDY
GIULIANI MURDERING UNCLE SAM.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE MAYOR HAS
SEEN IT YET.
THE FORMER NEW YORK MAYOR,
ATTORNEY FOR THE PRESIDENT, RUDY
GIULIANI.
I'VE SEEN YOU THE YEARS As A
MAYOR, I KNOW YOU CAN TAKE A
PUNCH, IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME
TO TAKE A SHOT AT YOU.
I WANT TO GO TO THE ISSUE OF HOW
YOU GOT INVOLVED AND I WANT TO
GO TO THAT BIDEN TAPE.
REMEMBER WHAT NANCY PELOSI SAID,
OH, TRUMP IS GUILTY OF A
SHAKEDOWN USING TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
HE SAID THAT ON LIBERAL JOE.
THE ONLY ONE INVOLVED IN A
SHAKEDOWN USING TAXPAYER
DOLLARS, THAT WOULD BE JOE BIDEN
ON TAPE.
>> SURE.
THIS PHONY CHARGE BEGAN WITH
IRONICALLY, RIGHT?
WITH THEIR CLAIMING THAT THE
PRESIDENT THREATENED ZALINSKY
WITH A CUTOFF OF MILITARY AID,
$400 MILLION IF HE DIDN'T
INVESTIGATE BIDE.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T DO THAT.
IT'S CLEAR.
MILITARY AID WASN'T EVEN ON THE
TABLE THEN.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT BIDEN DID.
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT ON SOME CRAZY
TRUMPED UP, EXCUSE THE
EXPRESSION, CHARGE.
THEN DOES BIDEN HAVE TO BE
INVESTIGATED?
AND WHY IS IT SO HARD TO GET
BIDEN INVESTIGATED?
>> Sean: WELL, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THAT.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO DO THAT,
MR. MAYOR?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THE SCANDAL, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CHOKING AMERICA ARE THE CORRUPT
PRESS.
AND THE CORRUPT DEMOCRATS THAT
HAVE BEEN COVERING UP THIS
PAY-FOR-PLAY SCHEME NOW FOR TWO
OR THREE YEARS.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE SITUATION.
IT'S TWO SITUATIONS.
MILLIONS IN THE UKRAINE, BES IN
CHINA.
JOHN KERRY IS INVOLVE IN THE ONE
IN CHINA.
>> SO IS WHITEY BULGER'S NEPHEW?
>> ISN'T THAT EXTRAORDINARY?
THE MONEY FROM CHINA GOES TO
WHITEY BULGER'S NEPHEW, THE
STEPSON OF THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE SON OF
THE PRESIDENT AND THEY'RE COMING
AFTER ME FOR REVEALING IT.
I SHOULD BE -- I SHOULD BE A
WHISTLEBLOWER.
I BROUGHT OUT WHAT THE
WASHINGTON PRESS, THE CORRUPT
WASHINGTON PRESS HAS BEEN
COVERING UP FOR TWO OR THREE
YEARS.
AND TO THIS MOMENT, THEY BELIEVE
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT DID I CONDUCT THE
INVESTIGATION CORRECTLY AS
OPPOSED TO IS WHAT I FOUND TRUE
BUT ROCKS THE FOUNDATIONS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT WHEN YOU HAVE THIS
KIND OF PAY FOR PLAY AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS.
REMEMBER, THIS IS PRECISELY WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON IN THE
FOUNDATION.
WHAT DID OBAMA KNOW AND WHEN DID
HE KNOW IT?
IN DECEMBER OF 2015, "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" EXCORIATED BIDEN FOR
THIS CONFLICT OF INTEREST HAVING
THE SON JUST TOSSED OUT OF THE
MILITARY FOR DRUG PROBLEMS PUT
ON THE BOARD OF THE MOST CORRUPT
COMPANY IN UKRAINE WHILE HE WAS
GIVING OUT BILLIONS IN THE
UKRAINE.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, YOU ONCE
WORKED IN THE PRESTIGIOUS
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
A LOT OF GREAT LAWYERS HAVE COME
OUT OF THERE, INCLUDING
YOURSELVES, ANDY McCARTHY,
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
AISLE, EVEN.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: LOOKING AT BIDEN, HIS
SON, WHAT HE ADMITTED TO ON
TAPE, THE CASE OF CHINA, HE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY BACKGROUND
EXPERIENCE OF PRIVATE EQUITY OR
ANYTHING THAT I KNOW.
IT'S $1.5 BILLION ABOUT 35
SECONDS.
>> BANK OF CHINA IS HIS PARTNER
AND WHITEY BULGER'S NEPHEW.
THAT $1.5 BILLION WAS TO BUY JOE
BIDEN.
>> ANY LAWS BROKEN?
>> NO OTHER EXPLANATION FOR IT.
MEANWHILE, THEY WERE CAVING IN
ABOUT THE ISLANDS, TARIFFS.
THERE WERE REPORTS IN THE NEW
YORK TIMES HOW SOFT BIDEN WAS ON
CHINA.
NOW WE SAY, HEY, MAYBE THE $1.5
BILLION MADE HIM A LITTLE SOFT.
THIS IS HORRIBLE.
IT'S HORRIBLE THAT I CAN'T GET
THE PRESS AND EVEN THE FBI WHO
IS TURNING DOWN THESE
ALLEGATIONS, THAT'S WHY THE
UKRAINIANS CAME TO ME.
THEY SAID THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH YOUR FBI.
>> Sean: AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
LAST THING, FACT, THE STATE
DEPARTMENT ASKED YOU TO LOOK
INTO IT.
>> I GOT ALL OF THE MEMOS, ALL
OF THE TEXTS.
THEY ASKED ME, I REPORTED IT
BACK.
AND THANKED ME FOR THE GOOD WORK
I DID.
>> Sean: GOOD FOR YOU.
MR. MAYOR.
IT'S IMPORTANT -- IT'S
IMPORTANT.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT FACT.
SIR, THANK YOU.
>> INVESTIGATE BIDEN, THEN
INVESTIGATE ME.
>> Sean: OKAY.
OKAY.